[Music]
please don't get involved
what is happening thickies stickers
thicker tears three thicker rats what's
up dick boy fam
it is monday morning june
13th lovely cloudy okay a little hazy
monday morning here in calabasa
california how you guys doing man
oh you're good oh your cat he survived
very cool that's cool man uh how's your
kiddo doing uh my kiddos started both of
them started summer camp today
my two-year-old boston i have horrible
anxiety right now because he's barely
two and he's going to summer camp from 8
30 a.m to 2 p.m and he's two
his mom thinks it's good for him i
disagree
he was pretty excited to go uh see make
friends because his best friend is his
brother who's six and he's two
so we'll see how that goes parents know
what i'm talking about it's a beast i
have anxiety but uh wifey's staying
close by just in case he freaks out once
he realizes we're not there anymore so
see how it goes hope he doesn't hit
anybody um
of that man fresh off the plane from
portland shout out to portland
hands down
best five shows i've had
prior to the pandemic i would say in the
seven years doing stamp comedy it is top
five of all time it was on freaking real
um
portland's interesting man portland is a
[ __ ] show
portland is a [ __ ] show certain
cities as a comic it's tough man like i
had to reschedule my uh
san francisco dates this coming weekend
because they recalled the district
attorney
and people aren't going out to clubs and
restaurants and we knew there was a
problem because my brother who's my tour
manager goes
man i'm looking at hotels like nice
hotels like then i think the ace hotel
we stayed in last time which is you know
the heart of san francisco san francisco
is not cheap by any means dude you're
talking
some of these hotels 60 bucks 80 bucks
no one's coming to the city so they
wanted to push the dates till things are
a little safer so
i'll have some uh
updates as far as when we're
rescheduling san francisco but
that's out of my control man uh these
cities that wanted to fund the police
and you know
um
slap criminals on the wrist and then put
them back on the streets it's it's uh
there's some consequences there and one
of them is me rescheduling dates
that's what it is like in portland we
stayed downtown and you'll see i'll post
the portland bit at a whole bit that i
wrote in the green room in portland
about how shitty the city is now as
outside so
most like i do the meet and greets right
i meet all the people of the meet and
greets
nobody's staying downtown they're all we
don't come down here one time we come
down here is do a comedy show or maybe a
restaurant but really unless we have to
be down there nobody's
staying in downtown portland it is
gotham city down there so
you know everyone stay on the outskirts
everybody's on the outskirts in portland
but
as far as uh
you know just
you know as a city it's i i love
portland man i mean i know they have
their issues downtown but um
it's such a freaking
fun time man
it's just it i have such a it's a i
don't know what it is i just love
portland not downtown a little dicey we
had an off-duty uh police officer come
in the show and he's like you boys going
out time like we never go out man
i'm a homebody of i'll go back to the
hotel i'll get a good meal and then shut
it down and he's like oh good i was
going to tell you man be careful out
here i was like what he's like yeah
we've had 22 shootings around
um voodoo donuts where i know you're
staying around there he's like 22
shootings past two days that's more than
we've had an entire month i was like
holy [ __ ] he's like but you're good if
you're like kind of with your crew but
i'll just stay in i'm like oh say less
but say less your boys staying in so
we stayed in man but shout out to
portland some of the best shows i've
ever had met so many great people some
of the sneakers out in portland you all
some sneaker heads that's one thing when
i do those meet greets or even just the
front row the crowd i look down the
sneakers some of these boys come with
heat man
it's rare i get beat by a fan and boy i
got beat this weekend even though i had
my custom kicks on shout out to the
styling irish you'll see i i rock these
orange white and black um
they look like travis scott's uh low
dunks those are custom made from the
styling irish this kid in ireland who's
getting into the custom sneaker game he
said let me see some kicks i said all
right let's do it man now usually when
people send me custom kicks uh they get
a little dicey they don't they fit weird
the logos might fall off um they just
they just you know they don't vibe well
you know if it rains like the paint
falls off it's a disaster it's like
wearing a fake rolex you've got to worry
about the rain so
um i warm to portland they held up in
the rain because it rained
every day there because it's portland
and uh you know i'm obsessed with those
shoes so i did get beat though someone
showed up in some freaking
yeezy nikes people showed up in travis
scott so shout out to portland man that
is such a great time so now we're
rescheduling san francisco due to the
crime wave um
we are i'm in la for a little bit so
i'll be doing uh spots all over la um
here until june 14th
um so i'll be doing spots all over la we
have i think companions coming up and
then uh on the 22nd which is next
wednesday it's job and friends all the
monsters will be there the monsters will
be there last shopping friends we had
the boys from are you garbage and dalia
this next one we have some monsters so
next uh kind of shop show just not me
doing sets with me my boys is at the
hollywood improv on the 22nd and then
the trash panna tour continues july 14th
the 16th
fort wayne indiana it's gonna be
interesting to come up with bits for
fort wayne for the for the jokes there
and then uh
off to san diego is july 21st to 23rd
then we end the trash pan of summer tour
august 4th through the 6th in baltimore
uh so yeah here we go man oh and they
just added appleton never even heard of
it appleton wisconsin september 8th
through the 10th appleton heard it's a
nice little town so see how that goes uh
yeah it's looking forward to it man
these are the new trash panda tour
shirts you can only get in person so if
you want to rock the gear you'll be able
to get this one in person this one's not
online
but uh let's get to the fights man
because we had some historic fights over
the weekend uh i had to watch it last
night and i again watch it this morning
the main three fights
um
you know it was in
um this fight was in uh
not singapore was it singapore yeah i
was in singapore
um
indoor so it's in singapore indoor
stadium which is huge usually uh what uh
one fc is always there so it's a big ass
arena
man i'll tell you what you look at how
the ufc is just so international now man
it's so international like it is a
worldwide sport i would say the growth
of the business and the future of the
ufc is all international i'll get into
that i think we're doing a shop short
this week where i dive into one
topic and we're going to dive into
camaro and leon edwards and i'll get
into all that but i do think that the
future of the ufc when you look at the
roster and you look at the
the prospects and even you look at the
champions
not a lot of americans men there's not a
lot of americans on there so i think uh
if i'm the ufc and having their i always
talk about their marketing meeting their
business meeting on monday mornings
you know the the kind of future of the
business is uh international
so you know we'll jump right into it you
know
the three main fighters who won this
weekend um
to the point are all all non-american uh
fighters uh so
now you have a a different uh light
heavyweight champion yuri now if you bet
on uh
if you watched last week's shop show
uh picks for this ufc uh we need some
grease on ginseng you know if you pick
uh if you did the parlay i had yuri
shevchenko and whaley
which i love when i get those right and
they're all favorites so i'm not saying
anything new
but you know it boosts your odds it's
with draftkings that's all fine and
dandy but they're all favorites
but a part of me it's like
you know i told you
did i pick him right yes did it go how i
think it would go absolutely not i don't
know anybody i don't know i think it is
a plus two thousand if you pick gear you
just submit glover textura
in the fifth round with 28 seconds left
it that is insane man you know and then
you know if you look at that fight and
i've watched it twice now
if
glover just
didn't make some mistakes you're talking
about he's he defended his title he's
the champ but he had choked down 28
seconds
when you watch the fight and if you've
been a glover fan which i have for a
long time and i've been a yuri fan even
when he's in rising bro right when he
fought
mala dendo and all that so yuri's a
beast
and i've been a yuri fan i've been on
years nuts for quite some time now but i
think there's an argument to say
that you know i think the general public
can say oh that was a great fight but i
would assume if you ask yeri if you ask
glover and yuri has kind of alluded to
this in his post fight press conference
going that was an off nightmare that i
do not i'm sure you guys enjoyed that
but that's not how i want to fight you
know he had massive cuts head trauma for
both gentlemen he's out for a hot second
i bet he fights end of 2022 now and
we'll get to who who i think he's gonna
fight but
i think what happened here is one of the
reasons you got such a good fight but it
sucks for yeri and for glover i think
both of them had enough night i think
geary was out of it i think glover was
out of it and then just
put that together you get an amazing
fight but there are so many mistakes
that is very uncommon for these two
gentlemen especially a guy like glover
who has so much experience like when he
has year he rocked and he goes for that
guillotine and year he slips out or out
glover's getting swept you know and uh
yuri going for the head arm triangle
against a black belt in glovertex era
like there are so many mistakes by each
guy and for yuri you know obviously was
he 27 he's a younger guy there might be
some mistakes there but for glover to
make those mistakes 29. here he's 20 29
but he has he has over you know good
amount of fights so it for him to make
these so just 32 fights he's 29 wins you
know so 29 and three is a [ __ ]
monster but
it's just you know he um
you know he only has three fights you've
seen as the the world champion so that's
great and i i picked him to win i don't
think he'd win like this i do think one
of the reasons he won was gloverhead and
off night you've never seen gloverat
with his experience making these
mistakes he had him rocked on the feed a
lot of times
you know so i think it was a product of
both guys having an off night maybe it's
because it's in singapore or maybe it's
because the title shot but for and i
expect that out of year even though he
has 32 fights
i know he's rising champ
ufc is a complete different animal so i
think fighting glove tech sarah in the
main event clover being a veteran
i expect gear to have some mistakes but
you're talking monumental mistakes man
monumental now it's great because both
guys were rocked well close to getting
finished
but even and this is even more to the
point where yeri
i don't i yeah even though scorecards
but even the mma experts quote unquote
nobody had gary winning this fight he
was down on the scorecards man this
thing goes 20 more seconds he you know
he's back to the drawing board he's not
champion so you know i think it's uh
it's just a pr it's not that it's a
great fight but these guys fight a
hundred times you're not getting that
fight i think if they fought again i i
do think gary wins and you're gonna see
a completely different fighter
now if you are a yuri fan which i am
you got to be a little nervous
that you know
he has this very free style he he prides
himself on being a warrior bushudo
warrior this japanese warrior and you
know and he has a very loosey-goosey
style he doesn't you know subscribe to
one certain style
so his hands are down his footwork is
unconventional his movement's
unconventional
but unless he's very disciplined that's
not going to get you in a lot of trouble
especially in the ufc i think you can
get away with in these other
organizations with the ufc and you're
fighting these monsters you know we'll
get to who's going to fight next but you
find these upper echelon guys
you know you got to be a little more
careful you know he does get hit and
stuff like that but but again
i think with year he had an off night
glover had an off night both made a lot
of mistakes it was a fantastic fight for
the fans but in general you don't want
to see a guy if you're investing stock
in a year you fight like that again and
to that point i think the light
heavyweight division that belt i think
gets circulated just nonstop i think
that thing gets passed around like a
doobie at a snoop dogg concert just here
you go here you go here you go here you
go i i think you're going to get
multiple world champions in the next two
years and when i look at the the
division you know unless there's some
freak that comes along soon that we
haven't heard of you're not getting
another jon jones in this lifetime a guy
who's just absolutely dominant and i
think it's kind of a good thing it's
tough for the casuals because they like
to you know six-time defending world
champion casuals like to build that up
so the ufc is gonna have to get you know
their marketing teams be doing work
let's see what you're made of because
now you have all these different guys
and they're not american the only
american that's gonna get close to
sniffing that title shots anthony smith
outside that it's going to get dicey for
the ufc and their marketing team because
you have you have glover brazilian you
have yawn right polish you have yuri you
have freaking racket you have uh mega
med right uh and then you have anthony
smith theo santos so you know it gets a
little dicey as far as the marketing
team goes marking to the american crowd
which goes back to my point that the
future of the ufc is international only
i mean it's it's gonna be here in
america but in america kids have so many
options
in international they have options but
not like in america america really
really focus on nba nfl major league
baseball that's what we do because the
money's there there's also a blueprint
pop warner high school be good in high
school you get a scholarship to college
you play well in college you enter the
draft you go to the pros
fighting there's not really a blueprint
there's just not a blueprint so i don't
know any parents pushing their kids into
the ufc you know i think it's always
gonna be a problem then you look at the
culture that we're in now um
it's it's it's getting a dicey form not
a terrible thing but i just think the
future of the ufc is international you
look at the the talent and it's there so
back to the light heavyweight division
and what's next for yerry i think his
first title offense will be against yon
and i do think glovers stylistically is
the toughest match up for yuri so
passing that test
was a big deal for him but he's very
remember he was down on those cards
if that goes decision he lost that fight
but he was able to pull it off
um
so you know for yerry i don't think that
that's though i think that was the worst
version of yuri we've seen and he's
still a world champion so there's pluses
but i do think the next guy whether tian
was the winner of uh mega megamed vs
anthony smith which i do think is for
the the next title shot so if it's yon
or the winner of smith versus uh megamed
you know you're going to get a better
version of yuri and for yerry glover was
the toughest matchup a vet
good you know he he's a boxer grappler
he doesn't come you know he's not very
loosey-goosey like these other guys
these other guys don't commit to a style
so they're free like yeri so i think for
yeri he could defend the title and he is
a guy with who has you know this
unconventional style so it's gonna be
tough for those other guys the game plan
for him but you know if you're talking
uh racket who's out for a while with
that [ __ ] acl but racket yuri you
know it's very unconventional that
that's going to be a typhoon of style so
i i do think he passed his toughest test
pass it because he got that finished
very late but prior to that he was
losing that fight the entire time now if
they want to do a rematch of glover uh
yuri i'm all for it i do think gary
beats him they fight again he's gonna
learn from his mistakes and not fight
like that
but but notice remember hamzat now yuri
has a lot more experience than hamza
mura hamza jumped from 11 to the number
one contender in the welterweight
division
fought with his heart got it done
but you know these these guys without
the high level experience they're
fighting off heart and they're passing
this test which is great but for yerry
and hamza because they had
they had these huge tests these
absolutely huge tests and they passed
them but if they continue to fight like
that they won't be in the ufc that long
but i think gary and hamza both are
going to learn and their next opponents
if they're expecting that version of
yuri hamza you're in for a rude
awakening because even geary in his post
fight press conference said
i'm sure you guys enjoyed that i did not
enjoy that i got tightened up i'm a
warrior i don't want to feel like this
because also took a lot of damage man
you can't fight like that you just can't
fight like that and yeri's gonna learn
that you know patty pillman to that
point he's gonna learn you can't at the
uf at the upper echelon the ufc you
can't get hit like that very long you
have a very finite career man it's a
marathon not a sprint so
for yerry who prides himself on being
this bushido warrior and stuff like that
the goal is not to get hit there's
nothing bushido about this now you have
a warrior's heart and you pass the test
against a phenomenal champion but you
can't keep fighting like that and he
knows that and he could i could almost
tell in his post-fight press conference
he was almost embarrassed he fought like
that he had a huge gash over his eye now
it's interesting which makes me love
yuri even more even when glover's on top
of him throwing that ground and pound
he's talking to him you know he's
speaking to him going that's all you got
i'm fine he's smiling nice smiling then
boom that big elbow that gave him that
huge gash you know so again those antics
at a certain level work but here you
paid the price that huge [ __ ] gas man
now also that gash with the blood coming
out could also been the reason you know
blood is very oily and slick so when
glover got that world-class guillotine
you know he's a black belt that might
have helped you get out of it so
to each its own you know but
um i think what's next for him is you're
probably gonna get the winner of uh
anthony smith
and uh megamed
you know but let's say magamed wins you
got yerry magamad uh you know but i
could see them getting it and it's also
going to be how long year he's out but i
really think i'd give to yon who's
coming off that big win
against rakic even though racket's knee
blew out you got to give it to yon
but also just from a marketing point if
fury can beat clover who's a champ then
he can beat frickin jan blakovich who
was a champ who fans are familiar with
it solidifyziri so i think what's next
for here is yan and i do think gian is a
much easier fight than glover i also
think you're gonna get the a really
really
focused more controlled version of very
against yan i think he gets it done i
think he knocks him out so
um
if you're yuri and you're a fan of yuri
and even yuri i'm sure today would say
the same thing i'd love to have him on
the show you know i think he's like all
right that was insane let's not do that
again because you're gonna be the fc
maybe two more years keep fighting like
that you know and then eventually that
chin's gonna go
i take that many much punishment from a
guy clover you look at the other guys
yawn hits like a [ __ ] mack truck a
polish mack truck if mac uh trucks were
made in poland he hits like that you
know uh racket no punk uh mega med you
know he's not the most
dangerous striker but still monster
anthony smith hits like a [ __ ] tank
tario santos you know domicres who you
already beat so
there's some monsters there man you know
there really are there's some monsters
there so
we'll see what happens i would love if
uh alexander uh gus finn got back on the
winning track because that's something
we can market
every fans familiar with alexander
gusfin he does have a fight with krylov
coming up if he were to win that one you
can toss his name into the hat and as he
works his way up you know he's probably
at his level if he beats krylov and they
give him you know uh santos or a
dominant graves he gets one more win
boom title shot and that that name
recognition for a guy like yerry to beat
him who had those wars with john and dc
like that would go a long way so i could
definitely see him doing that you know
but uh yeah i do think jan's next i i
really do i think john's next it makes
most sense but just how how is yuri
gonna heal and then um you know you got
a lot of contenders but you know you
look at the depth of the the light
heavyweight division which was a
freaking
nightmare just a few uh years ago you
know it was kind of in this weird land
once jon jones left and dc retired and
gusto went to heavyweight it was in a
weird space man it was in a really weird
space so
you look at the
the talent pool at light heavyweight
you know
a lot of foreigners
a lot of foreigners that's to the point
the uc is going to have to double down
on their international marketing because
it's there and you look at that
singapore crowd like that place was not
so's dude yeah not so's
you know so england's obviously popping
and you know they they they have a
chance to
have a another champion since michael
bismi and leon edwards which got
announced against kamar usman which i
think is camaro's toughest test so
we'll get into that on the shop uh
breakdown this week but um
you know
that main event was exciting for the
fans but but i do think it was the worst
version of yuri and glover but shout out
to yuri for passing the test
for glover you know
they're not gonna do a rematch
uh the yawn fight's not happening so
you know i don't know what they do with
them
if you don't give anthony smith and
mogamed the the title shot they fight
glover you just stay busy you know so i
think glover has
one fight left um if he were to win that
and they offered him a total shot he'd
stick around but uh one fight he lose
that he's gonna retire you know so you
can get another uh kind of legend um
he's gonna retire fairly soon here
in the co-main event uh chefchanko
versantos now i told you guys uh you
know shevchenko
remember when i do the shop picks i
gotta assume you guys are gonna bet on
those i want you to win so i'm not gonna
play with your money now me personally i
put a thousand dollars on santos because
she was a plus seven hundred
you look at her style
you know and i chef chenko is getting a
tad older maybe a
a step slower a little bit santo's
grappling style should definitely have
the advantage there and it showed man it
showed so
you know the these judges the one i gave
4946 is absolutely smoking crack cocaine
let's be honest here um
but you know
looking at the fight
i hate to say somebody got robbed but
you know it's hard not to give santos
those first three rounds just going into
the after the first three once the third
round ended in my head i'm like oh chef
jenkins needs to finish to pull this off
shifting definitely needs to finish
santo's a much better grappler obviously
on the feet the world of difference but
i would say as far as grappling goes
santos uh you know has the same
advantage that chef chang has on the
feed on the ground even though
chefchenko took her down but when she
took her down
you know the grappling and the just the
rolling of santos really showed so i had
santos up three rounds now you can give
shivchenko the fourth and fifth whatever
you want she still lost that fight
you know so i think for shevchenko
um
i don't know if i'm shivchenko
if i want to see santos again santos is
young santa isn't that old so i think
for shevchenko i don't know how serious
she took it you know i i heard bisping
and uh john x saying the the fighter
meetings chefchenko they were like oh
what advantage do you see santos him she
goes none this girl has no advantage
anywhere inside that octagon i'm a
destroyer
which i you know if you're chefchanko
the pound for pound you know best we
have to offer in any female fighting you
know you have to have that attitude but
a part of me goes on maybe she
overlooked santos you know santos if you
look at a record
there's a debate here where she beat
shefchenko the pound for pound great and
then her last only last and only loss
was a split decision
uh three years ago february uh ferry's
second to no not 19. so three years ago
in a split decision i think she won that
fight so
really you know and then look at chef
chanko this girl should probably she's
one judge away from being undefeated you
know so she's young
if they were to do a rematch
it makes sense too it makes sense
because for shivchenko it's you know if
they do a rematch again
like people obviously a yeary glover
rematch
you know i think gary tightens up and
and destroys glover theory match for
chef chanko i think ah
this is probably santo's best shot to
beat her the judges kind of screwed her
if they fight again i think chef chain
could have a much
better perspective and respect her a lot
more and probably fight a little
different and probably beats her if
their rematch but if i'm chef chanko i'm
not rematching right away you know no
matter what the judges scored it but i
would you know look at fighting going up
a division fight the winner of uh pena
amanda nunes that's what i'll do if chef
chanko and then
have santos get one win under belt and
then come back down
you know
so i did think jeff jenker lost that
fight
i really do but uh i was glad that well
i'm not even glad i you know even my
picks i'm not married to him so
fear is fair i thought santos won that
fight and it sucks what's interesting
about her and she's what kind of person
she is she didn't complain about did she
she didn't even mention the refs she's
like i'm young i'll be champ and i agree
with that 100 percent like the division
i don't know who's going to beat that
girl because chef schanger didn't beat
her so
uh they fought against pretty well but
no nor here now we're there and then uh
you know the i think the
the people's uh main event was uh zheng
vs johanna young gencheck
um
you know there was a lot of
assumptions that they were just going to
carry on and this can be the same great
fight that they had you know possibly
the greatest women's fight of all time
it's tough to live up to that
expectation but that first round man
it's kind of a continuation of that
first fight they went at it but they
went at it but zhang was kind of
whipping her ass
zhang was laying a lot you know the
the narrative here was what version of
joanna are we gonna get
that that was a big question mark here
and it you know is joanna still at that
top level that we come to known her for
right like she's a beast she's been out
a little bit she wants to start her
family she goes in this fight first
round she loses gets pretty [ __ ]
mollywhopped and then uh spinning
backfist flatline ko
so joanna retires god shout out to her
man what a legend absolute legend i
think it's the right call i don't think
you stick around after this um you know
sometimes we stick around too long it
gets pretty dicey for a ufc fighter so i
like when people get out like all right
i'm out man i want to see if i could
hang with the top i can't i got cage
spinning backfist i'm out that's my time
like a blackjack dealer that's my time
so shout out to johanna man with the
greatest never do it some phenomenal
fights you know should be a first ballot
hall of famer in the ufc and for uh zang
you know now it's a title shot for zang
that's how that goes
um
yeah she looked like a beast you beat
the shot joanna that first round then
the second round spinning ko walk off
home run uh knockout is pretty tough to
watch if you're a yohanna fan but god
bless her [ __ ] she wants you to start a
family suit so go do your thing girl we
wish you the best here
uh the rest card you know jake matthews
phenomenal huge win huge win uh jack
della amazing win got past the the test
of a dagstand wrestler did the damn
thing uh brendan allen looked phenomenal
[Music]
uh you know
i thought he won that fight his name is
brendan so i'm a little biased
but good card overall man good card
overall
great card overall today on the show we
have calvin koehler who's fighting this
saturday against josh emmett he's
fighting austin texas on a five
round main event i guess against josh m
it is a phenomenal fight i can't wait
for this one so we have calvin kader on
the show today um so it should be fun
kevin's one of my favorite people man
just a great fighter
um
uh where where the uh though the card
for fight night this card is stacked i'm
actually pretty good i'm crunk fort man
i'm crunk for it i'm crunk for this card
uh you know what are the odds on on uh
his fight here
there it is
calvin's a favorite minus 235
that seems fair
that seems fair
coming off that giga win
and joshua is going off to win joshua's
a beast man that's a great fight that's
a war
that's a war man you got buckley on
there yeah tim means kevin holland
that's a great fight then you got the
old heads cerrone joe lauzon
cerrone favorite in that fight
lauzon hasn't found a hot second so i
assume that has something to do with it
but overall just a fun card really fun
card i'm excited free fun cards take my
money
even though it's not pay-per-view but
when i say take my money i mean you know
my subscription money
eddie weiland cody stamen jesus christ
coach damon's a freaking minus 5 10.
so big favorites on the card man but
yeah
i'm excited for this fight night really
excited all right thickies let's take a
little break gotta pay some bills by
doing some of these ads and before we
jump into the interview with calvin
keator listen fellas i was just in
portland did a thousand meet and greets
some of y'all losing your hair man some
of you are it just is what it is we can
do something about it because two out of
three men will experience some form of
hair loss by time the 35
more than 50 million bros will suffer
from male pattern baldness my friends at
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors all right keeps
offers a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your freaking
hair you meet with a doctor virtually
you meet with a doctor then medications
are delivered straight to your door
every three months you don't have to
even leave your home we have 24 7 care
and support it's low cost treatments are
at 10 a month keeps offers generic
versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss all
right ten dollars a month to keep your
dope locks what are we doing here man
how do they stay in business they have
everything you need to keep your hair
it's delivered straight to your door
discreet little package shows up proven
results
all right remember prevention is ski
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act right now you
don't want to look like brian callen
when it comes your hair save more spend
less if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
shobb to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-p-s dot
com shop s-e-h-a-b to eat your first
month free keeps.com shop
some of y'all boys freaking out man
because crypto markets sucked you right
in the tummy you lost a lot of your
money you're like what am i gonna do i
feel you and listen i wish i could
relate but i can't because i got
masterworks in my corner that's right
masterworks they help normal guys like
you and me diversify my portfolio with
their blue chip art from masters like
picasso monet bathgwat all right
diversifying with art isn't new it's not
new like crypto or some of this other
stuff you're investing flying cars
aliens whatever you're investing in the
ultra wealthy have done it for centuries
when you realize blue chip art prices
outpaced the s p 500 by 164 for the last
25 years it makes sense man all right
i'm a fan of masterworks which is why
i'm teaming up with them join over the
330 000 members get priority access to
masterworks with my unique link go to
masterworks dot art
shop s-h-a-b that's master works dot art
shop see important disclosure at
massworks dot io slash disclaimer that's
masterworks dot art slash shobb
mr calvin kater how you doing brother
doing great how are you doing you look
good man jesus christ handsome bastard
yes at austin heat we got in here
thursday so i'm frying out here in this
hundred and ten hundred plus degree
weather yeah man everyone thinks it's
cool to move to texas till the summer
comes about
yeah you ain't lying man a lot of
different critters around here too yeah
dude different type of mosquitoes out
there they get them thick mosquitoes man
they'll suck the freaking blood out your
face
yeah they got the cockroaches they got
the tarantulas scorpions they got a pig
problem they shoot pigs out of
helicopters out there they see forum too
right they blow him up out here yeah man
it's pretty lit tim kennedy if he i
don't know if he's out there or not
right now he's on his book tour but if
he's there
you can link up with him and slaughter
pigs with him out of a helicopter i
don't know if you're looking to do that
this week
yeah maybe next week when i can eat them
yeah there you go man how's the uh how's
the weight cut going it's going man
they're never fun but um you know
i like to pride myself and never miss
and wait you know and that'll be the
time i miss it but um you know always
showing up and feeling great
um almost almost show time man it's
fight week monday let's go yeah man
you're professional i'm never worried
about you missing weight uh any desire
to move to austin from uh from the east
coast my man
i don't know about moving man for some
reason i'm a homebody backer i love it
in new england but i i love to um you
know have a we're talking about having a
place out here
um save on that six percent we were
talking about but yeah
that's six percent but we're just trying
to find reasons to move i could save six
percent in new hampshire
moved to austin man six percent
yeah it's the hype right now um
you know looking at this fight you know
you're you're uh were looking at before
you came on your your favorite you know
in regards to the draftkings i think a
lot of that is due to it being a
five-round fight obviously you're pretty
familiar being in the main event
fighting five rounds uh you know uh josh
emmett's not so i would assume that
favors you is that something you look at
as far as you know this this being a
five round fight
well first start off shout out to
draftkings but
yeah right
uh five five-round fight man it's cool
with some uh i've been used to now for
the last few fights i've been you know
fortunate enough to have these these
opportunities in front of me
and uh but you know as far as
the odds and all that [ __ ] i don't get
caught up in that and yeah you know uh
emma maybe hasn't fought as many
five-round fights as me but uh you know
he's a tough opponent he's a he's got a
strong skill set that he brings to the
table and
um you know
i never i never try to get to round four
five but if it happens i'm always ready
yeah i think this fight too in
particular like once it was announced
everyone's like ooh that's a fight man
like it's such a
an important fight in the featherweight
division too you know if you you know
because you you fought max holloway
obviously didn't go your way then you
fight giga in a you know great fight for
you which is a huge win and then now
you're fighting emmett who's ranked
behind you but you look at the division
it makes sense because i would assume
uh if you were to pass this test which i
think you do if you pass this test yeah
i would assume you fight the maybe the
winner of ortega yair you know i i don't
know the division is interesting right
now man there's so many monsters but
you've also fought a lot of the guys
yeah man it's
the featherweight division stacked right
now
um i i choose to stay busy man time and
time again you know all these other guys
kind of sit around and try to find the
the let the guys fight you know and get
acute with the division man and i prefer
to just try to stay busy
i think that's what the great fighters
in this division do you see max fight
yaya when he was probably arguably next
for the title anyway correct um like
that about you know the guys that want
to stay busy and compete and earn their
shots and um you know emmits emmett's
another one that you know he's coming
off a recent injury so um
i don't think it was his fault why he
was inactive but i feel like he's
another one that's trying to go and earn
it so that always makes for a hell of a
fight
yeah i agree man you know looking at
your past few fights
you know that as a fan of you you know i
love the [ __ ] eddie i love max too but
so i hated that you guys fought so
watching that max holloway fight
because you learn the most in your
losses every fighter knows it's like you
know you can learn a good amount in your
wins but you learn them
a lot it says a lot about a fighter
coming off a loss
you know and that's a tough pill to
swallow when you lose a guy like max
holley even though he's a great he's a
legend but you you want that feather in
your freaking cap man so because you win
that one you you know we're going
sizzler you know you're you're buying
all of new england so was there uh was
there a learning
experience kind of from the max hallway
fight
like you said man i i learned off uh you
know wins and losses you know the losses
stand out more but i try to learn off
wins when i can
uh it's a hard pill to swallow for sure
every every losses but you know i feel
like it's harder for everybody else and
more the public it's more of a a talking
point of thing for a lot of people but
commitment correct
it is what it is like i'm on i'm past it
if it was a win just like giga i don't
give a [ __ ] about that fight either i
want to end it like yeah
yeah it's always forward with me and uh
you know there's definitely things we
learned to pick up from that fight and
things i already knew about myself that
people got to see you know and uh like
what
like the heart the toughness you know
things like that i feel like some people
tell me that was one of their favorite
fights of mine i'm like [ __ ] you
but but uh maybe they're watching enough
of my damn fights but yeah
you know whatever man if that inspired
people cool
you know what i mean i'm happy for that
whatever but i'm out here just trying to
change my life every opportunity that i
get to step in there is a chance for me
to do that trying to chase that life on
the other side of a win i say it every
time
yeah i think the anybody who watched the
max hallway fight and they're like oh i
didn't know calvin was tough i'd like
what the [ __ ] you been doing dude like
what the [ __ ] what are you talking about
you know i think too that night matt it
was a it was a special night for max you
know like you just on sometimes it
happens you guys they just have those
fights that just happened that night you
know i'd love to see you guys fight
again so obviously you're not looking
past giga but it's like
you know you lost the max which isn't a
big deal you know you showed your
toughness and if it boosts your fan base
great but you know you look at the
division so you know for you how do you
see you know kind of you get a title
shot obviously this is the reason why
you do this to be champ
yeah yeah
that's just winning man you keep winning
they can't deny you that was my mindset
getting into the ufc and that's my
mindset guy get into that title fight
you know it's just they can't deny if
you keep on winning and um and
right now we got a tough opponent with
josh admit i know he's he's uh gunning
for me everyone's probably overlooking
him you know you say i'm the favorite
but i keep that underdog mentality and i
know it's a dangerous one to have i'm
sure josh has it now
and i'm not looking to let him build any
momentum off it
yeah because it you know you're
obviously ranked higher and you i think
you have the bigger name you're the more
well-known guy and you're your favorite
go in this fight when i was fighting i
used to hate when people told me the
odds so i apologize for that you say
like i remember i was fighting roy
nelson i was walking around palms casino
you know my first ufc fight in the main
event against [ __ ] roy nelson i have
three fights he's 30. i'm walking around
the the casino and everyone's like
you're an underdog man i put money on
you and you're like oh cool cool cool
man thank you
yeah that's going to help me
also so the experts think i'm going to
lose thank you for that thank you
i'm going to want to win just a little
bit more for you and your [ __ ] 300
bucks
yeah and uh how's camp been camp went
good for you
yeah good man um i i really
i haven't really slowed down much at
this point you know you try to make it
more just that lifestyle non-stop
we've been traveling i think traveling
is really the the harder part you know
they'll mix up in camps little curve
balls but back home i'm nice and routine
and
um
things been good man feeling great the
whole team's out here now and uh these
fight weeks man more than anything i'm
just grateful for my team you kind of
slowed down a little bit on fight week
you see the team out here with you
grinding putting in the work and you
know i just appreciate them being here
uh being here again behind me and
we all have the same goal in mind and
that's getting the w on saturday night
yeah i think too your team the new
england cartel you know you guys are
probably the close closest team that i
know like he has a close close man like
a close-knit family which i admire man
small groups man um you know there's no
fluff around here we don't need it we
prefer to you know to to go without it
and um
everybody here adds value and uh
yeah there's no fluff to cut you know no
no fat we're gonna trim the fat around
here all
uh tight-knit team and everyone carries
their own weight
and and how do you see this emmett fight
going he's obviously you know his
background is wrestling he's a nia guy
but you know he does have some power in
his hands you know you look at some of
his knockouts
high school methuen rangers ranger pride
baby
yeah he's a beast
he carries power late in the rounds you
know so if it goes late we're ready for
that uh for me it's always the same man
i always just envision myself getting my
hand raised and then uh i let the if the
finish happens i let it present itself
on fight night but i'm just looking to
get my hand raised and um
and like i said chasing that life on the
other side of the wind man uh you know
you keep winning they can't deny you
yeah i think too with with emmett you
know in recent interviews he's been
talking about how he's been focusing on
boxing because obviously you know
boxing's one of your specialties
so i think for him a lot of boxing focus
which
you know
when guys focus on certain aspects of
the game i you know
it's not like he's gonna outbox you you
know he has that he has power for sure
but you know when guys focus too much on
what the other guy does
you know there's not enough hours in the
day for for josh emmett to be as good as
the boxers you are you know so
for for
fighters out there when they tell me i'm
like you can focus on that man but do
what you do you know do what you do man
you don't want to focus on this stuff
too much
i don't know what connor said about
khabib he focused too much on wrestling
from defensive positions
and you know what he what got him to the
show you know what got him to the fight
i agree with that man but you know a
little bit of balance of both it's a
fine line like you're talking about i
think it's important
to understand what this guy's strengths
are what he's good at but also not
forget no make him fight your fight not
the other way around yeah you're a bad
[ __ ] so it's like if if you just
focus on wrestling it's like what are we
doing man you know guys fall into that
trap 100 man no i think there's no
secret we're all in for a hell of a
fight hell of a show um austin's a great
place to do it my sister just had her
baby a month ago
congrats man
yeah so i finally just saw the baby this
week i'm excited to be out here um you
know ideally i'm planning on staying out
till wednesday after floating the river
having some fun and uh so texas is like
a second home for me now that my sister
moved out here and married a cowboy and
i'm taking it all in man i'm really
enjoying myself out here
saturday yeah i know you seem like
you're in good spirits so uh i'll get
your picks on some of these other fights
that got announced you know in your
division you got max holloway and
volkanovsky fighting that that rubber
match how you see that going down i
think the winner in that fight is the
fans
i agree 100 percent of the fight man
i was uh in abu dhabi i want to say i
feel like maybe i was fighting ige for
that when they were fighting uh the
second time it was very close i don't
know if i rewatched it um but that
second fight was really close if not
maybe i'd give max the edge but i know
you know the champ uh alex won the first
one for sure so third one's gonna be fun
um you know i i got uh confidence in
both guys so i don't really know who's
got that one to be honest yeah i had
volkanovsky on food truck diaries and i
told him just as far as a a fan which
i'm a fan of his you know for his legacy
i you
yeah i talked about food truck diaries
and i was just saying
you know that fight wasn't announced yet
and i said you know he was talking about
going to 55 and how he can easily make
55. he only trains with bigger guys and
he said and i said i get all that man
and you you want to pursue excellence
and uh the the light uh the lightweight
title i get all that i said but for me
as a fan and i think
you know especially as american like
for me to not not even co-signing it
didn't mean my [ __ ] approval but i'm
just saying you have to close that
chapter with max holloway you got to
beat him you know and make it clear in
order to move on with his legacy like it
has to be done because max follow he's
such a [ __ ] fan favorite everyone
loves him here yeah i can definitely see
that argument man but uh you know he's
also i respect both guys they they want
competitors they want challenges and uh
and they they want to be busy that's
what i like about it man they you know
they're busy the great champions house
champs should act you know taking on any
commerce um he just wants the best
challenge and uh and max is just you
know
max's max he's out here competing
earning a shot not not being bitter
about what happened and how it went down
but you know just focusing on what he
can control now and that's earning
another shot and he did that so it's
gonna make for a hell of a fight man i
can't wait to tune in for that one i'll
actually be out there i want to say they
got me yeah so i'm looking forward to
that one yeah that makes sense i what i
what i appreciate about especially the
the featherweight division guys like
yourself like you look at this weekend
like you and emmett have nothing but
respect for each other like you and josh
like there's not this entertainment woe
[ __ ] talking thing you know you look at
volkanovsky max holloway
you know yair uh ortega really doesn't
talk [ __ ] like the featherweights you
guys just let your skills do the talking
which i think for a while since conor
mcgregor and you know he did what he did
but and that was natural to him but
people went oh that's how you get likes
and people to tune in so guys started
doing this weird like promo bits and had
already thinking what they were going to
say on the mic with if it was dc or
rogan inside the or bisping inside the
outgun and to me it got kind of cheesy
and now i feel like guys like yourself
and volkanovsky and holloway like you're
like no no these guys are good i respect
that guy it's all good man it's me a
great fight which to me i i think is
more of respecting which is what the the
future of the ufc should head down yeah
with the sports kind of started off his
pound off his honor respect things like
that but yeah like you said man if as
long as you're authentic you know um
like that then it comes off
straight but if you if you're trying to
force it it comes out cheesy like you're
talking about and for me man it's like
they i never might i might not ever say
all the things they want to hear leading
into a fight those sound bites but i'm
always going to give give you what you
want to see on fight night you know and
that that's the way
um i don't want to represent myself yeah
your entire camp's like that rob font's
the same like i don't need a hot take
from rob or i don't need a hot take from
you like when you guys fight we tune in
man cause it's a great [ __ ] fight
yeah you know what you're gonna see man
and and i feel like josh emmitt got that
same style so
um you know the i appreciate these guys
and what they're capable of you know
they allow me my opponents to reach my
full potential on fight night you know
if if the thought of josh emmett
knocking me out or things like that
didn't uh you know get me to push it in
the gym every session then uh you know
that's what i need man i like these in
order to have main events man you know
you need to solid uh whoever you want to
call as the a or the b side you need a
solid opponent you know you don't get
big moment opportunities fighting cans
you know so uh you want big moment
opportunities then then you get to fight
top caliber opponents and uh
i know we got one in josh emmitt and i'm
i'm excited to have earned another big
moment opportunity as a main event here
in austin texas and
i couldn't be more excited to put it on
show for you guys man
no i agree i can't freaking wait this
this has been circled on the calendar
and think boys studios for a hot second
since it got announced so you know i'm
not a journalist so i can be biased but
you know who we're rooting for here my
man i hope you like this [ __ ] dude up
let's go i appreciate that man you
already know i can't wait to be a thick
boy all summer post w man yeah it's a
thick boy summer dog um
[Music]
did you uh uh i'll let we can end on
this you know so if
you're gonna get this win and then
what's the summer looking like my man
what are we doing we're going new
england you head up to jersey shore what
are we doing here so we got uh we got
five week ufc five week for there and
then um
actually before that though it is rob
fond's birthday so happy birthday rob
font on the 24th this month so
25th delete that um
edit that yeah and we got july 4th man i
haven't been able to really enjoy that
uh like the summer's too much uh so i'm
excited to just get some good grilling
in back in new england
and i'm sure i'll be balanced around a
little bit but i hear that they might be
coming to uh ufc might be coming to
boston maybe in uh september or august
or so so
as much as i like to plan all this [ __ ]
man i'll be right back in the [ __ ]
gym ready to go you know me yeah you
have to man so i'll be in boston i think
end of step the last week of september i
think september 29th through october 1st
i'm on tour in boston at uh laugh boston
so you and the boys got to come out man
how do you know i'm there 100
love it brother well i can't wait for
this weekend man uh i i just
you're gonna crush it brother i get such
a good vibe from you man soak up some of
that austin's son and uh keep doing your
thing brother room for you man
appreciate you guys thank you again for
having me for the time brother have fun
saturday
yes sir
what else you got jen uh first one is
just yuri's homecoming this is marco
romano
check this out this is czech republic
holy [ __ ]
well he's the first champ ever
in the czech republic
wow good for him man super cool what a
superstar
i love seeing this it's like
uh my boy cheeto vera he went back home
uh
to
ecuador ecuador and he sent me videos of
him and i was just like holy [ __ ] man
this is uh ariel's thing he was saying
he can't go anywhere just picking up his
nephew and he's got just bombarded by
all these fans
it's beautiful to see man it gives kids
hope you know look at him
got a freaking was that crab tattoo on
the back of his head is that new
he did not have the haircut when we saw
him the haircut is lit
yeah cheeto doing the goddamn thing and
with yuri too man it's like again
internationally it when you have a champ
you know even though cheeto is not a
champ he's been was he's had over 20
fights in the ufc now but for for
just those countries you know year in
czech republic it just inspires people
and then they get tuned in you if it's
one of your own man it's a big deal so
the czech republic now yuri's motivating
young kids there now they can do it you
know so it's pretty cool to see super
cool to see
uh this one came by surprise michael
venom page and mike perry are headlining
at bkfc
yeah
super never would have imagined this
yeah well that's one of the great things
about uh scott coker is he's open to
some of this stuff you know like the
reason you don't see ufc bellator
you know
kind of cross pollinate uh fighters just
because of dana he doesn't want to play
ball and i i get it from dana's
standpoint dude you don't want to build
another organization i'm with him on
that i would love to see musasi izzy
that's one of the number one fights i'd
make if i you know if i was scrooge
mcduck but i get why they don't do it
but uh mike even paige uh and mike perry
itch
it's in london i'm a tough fight for
your boy mike perry yeah as far as
distance control and stand up it's going
to be a tough fight for mike perry tough
tough fight those hooks and those loopy
hooks will be tough to land you have to
make it dirty you have to make it a dog
fight you sit outside and get eaten
alive very tough fight for mike perry
very very tough fight yep no take downs
or anything just straight up bearing up
sure
yeah so that was a trip it's fun that's
a fun fight of course huge for bkfc
because mike have been paige by far the
most talented
you know not out of his prime fun to
watch yeah fun to watch yeah uh that's
the same night you're going to talk
about it later but that same night is
also the kamara usman leon edwards part
two
and that's in salt lake city yeah i love
this so obviously you guys know this but
for those of you that don't um you know
this is this is a rematch but last time
they fought man it was a hot second you
know both are different fighters
camaro's a pound for brown champ for a
reason i would say this is his toughest
task colby is always a tough one he
passed but man leon edwards just doesn't
get his respect you know and he's going
uh for the the
the kind of illustrious um title of
being the the second champion to come
out of
england you know bisbee was the first
shot to michael bisping one of the
greats um who i thought did a phenomenal
job commentating you know filling him
for rogan because we're going to do the
international card so i thought he did a
great job with dc and anik you know so
for leon edwards it's a big deal man big
deal long time overdue long time overdue
super he's deserved it man yeah yeah but
again just because he's not you know the
most flashy or talked [ __ ] and super
marketable but they dude can't fight and
we're in the fight business
so this is the the right thing to do but
i'll get into that fight on the the shop
short this week
cool and that's us that's in salt lake
city interesting place to do it salt
lake city do we know who else is on the
card
i can look at her now yeah do we have
any like rumors or anything
luke rockhold paulo costa was a great
one yeah
uh glover tech chair had some
interesting comments about paulo costa
he was saying how he was like i think
he's gone too far as far as like his
social media he goes he has to decide if
he wants to be champ or if he wants to
be the kim kardashian of mma like he's
doing all this wild stuff and he goes
who am i to you know talk about it you
know because he has more followers than
me and maybe he's making money doing
this stuff but he goes all
glover goes i'll erase my freaking
social media after i'm out of the ufc i
don't give a [ __ ] so but he's like for
for uh costa it's like
you know is doing that stuff is it taken
away from you being a champ so he was
honestly look he has more followers than
me right maybe that's worth more money
down the line so who am i to talk if
that's his goal game more follows and be
the kim kardashian of instagram he's on
the right path now if his goal is to
become champion he has to leave the
controversies aside and focus on
training diet and what he wants agree
100
he goes i'm not saying he's right or
wrong if uh if we're talking about money
and followers he's right it's not my
gold half followers my goal was always
to be the best fighter in the world when
i retire from fighting i'll delete all
my social media
how cool is that yeah
yeah that's you know glover's an older
dude so you know i don't think he's the
most social media savvy guy
you know guys can do it you look at a
guy like izzy who's really good at
social media um you know sugar shawn
but but i'm with him because now the
narrative on uh costa it used to be what
a great fighter he was and now like
the kind of
pr that he's been doing it's a little
bit like oh he's like he's crazy he's
been really weird on twitter yeah it's
been kind of funny but still it really
started you know after he lost to izzy
and got on there was like oh i drank too
much red wine the night before y'all
wait what
and then the ufc has the hiccups with
some of the other stuff and just some of
his posts are strange very strange
there's a strange strange gentleman that
one where he has a focus in on his
armpit yeah he looked like a vagina
yeah i don't know man maybe just bored
and he's like dude this this is easy to
do so i like to be weird and you're like
all right do you man but
you know if you're if he was winning you
know what i'm saying
cool do your thing but it starts taking
away from that and that's the narrative
instead of your skills you got a problem
and that's and that's the problem that's
closest problem it's gone away from him
being this great fighter to us being
like that's kind of weird you know yeah
because you've got you look at sean
strickland who goes nuts on social media
too
and then there's like oh
people i don't think so people like oh
he's a little weird or a little
different he'll say some you know
off-colored [ __ ] which i enjoy if that's
how you feel do it that's like bryce
mitchell man people want to write all
these headlines when he was on here like
oh you gave him a platform do this [ __ ]
yeah dude i'm not gonna if that's what
he feels and then
remember be like i can't believe you
asked about gun control oh do you think
bryce is a buddy and we talk and he goes
hey man i'd like to talk about this
yes you think i just shot that out of
the bloom
huh
no bryce is a he doesn't want to just
talk about fighting man he talked about
his farm for [ __ ] 30 minutes you know
and i was into it i'm gonna go to a food
truck down this farm we're going to kill
his chicken i'm going to grill chicken
for us send me a food truck
now i'm going to be crying the whole
time because i probably can't kill a
chicken be honest probably save the
chicken that's where the difference is
me and bryce i'm going to save that
[ __ ] chicken
and he's never going to talk to me again
but you know bryce too
i like guys that are real so
the difference between like a sean
strickland bryce mitchell
compared to acosta it's like it's not
like cost to say anything political or
you know something he believes it's all
kind of like
you know
tick-tock i'm surprised in tick-tock
doing the dances and [ __ ] you know
wearing a thong or some weird [ __ ] to
get likes so because bryce and sean
strickland it's their truth like whether
there's camera with their social media
that's how those guys talk so it's very
natural and and they know they might get
some backlash for it but they can't help
it because that's who they are i like
those guys whether i agree with them or
not bryce's take on you know school
shootings being you know
the government being i don't subscribe
to that in any fast i don't i don't i
don't believe in that at all
but it doesn't make bryce a bad person
but also what i like about bryce when
he's talking about the school shooter
and he was
i don't think he's misinformation but he
got information i go ah that's actually
not true it wasn't this i i can see i
thought that was this is he goes well i
didn't know that oh that's cool that's
good to know it's not like he argued
with me and doubled down on it you know
he's a good person man these guys are
good guys you know
yeah i like that guy
yeah bryce is [ __ ] great yes
uh if you're a chicken
all right so
jorge masala accused conor of being on
steroids and this is recently you know i
was like may 30th but yeah and um more
plates for dates the derrick guy
he went through conor's usada testing
stuff and it says it's up to date but
apparently he was only tested one time
in 2021 and zero times in 2022. if this
if this website is actually updated
interesting yeah
and so what's he say about it
he's just saying like he's not he's not
saying conor's doing steroids but if you
wanted to you definitely could just
amount of testosterone if that's true
man that's what worries me is remember
the you
the ufc hired usada so usada works for
the ufc
so i'm curious on how much influence the
ufc has on who they're testing when
they're testing them
you know because for them not to test
connor for an entire year after
a leg break even though he's on a yacht
i know it's
tough but it's like
that's very strange
very strange
soda but so did and did he do the video
shatter place more dates follow him he's
the best in the business
um
so he did he do this based off of
jorge's yeah
and there's also you see what jorge said
what are we going to say jen some other
people have been accusing him of they're
not accusing him sorry remember anthony
smith and bismi had a conversation
right if you really wanted to do it we
talked about last week yeah that's right
yeah
so this is uh
you know i'm a little bigger although
now he's shooting up on steroids and all
kinds of things but he's still a little
boy i would love to fight at 170 but i
don't want wait for anyone if he wants
to do it i will break his face if you
don't want to do it let the next one
come
yeah uh he's especially much his life
everybody says that um
mozville welcomes a potential fight
against mcgregor accuses man of steward
used in a recent interview game break
called mcgregor fake says he will always
be a little boy to him despite his
supposed attempts to get bigger
through banned substance he is fake
maswal told espn deportes he knows that
i'm a man who hits hard and that i come
to kill i don't come to hug in the cage
i'm going to give everything inside me
to kill him aggressive i'm a little
bigger although now he's shooting up on
steroids all things he's still a little
boy
yeah i don't think that fight happens
i'd like to that'd be a great fight in
the build-up but yeah and that's if
connor wants to do it at 170.
it sounds like dana's favoring uh
chandler
he did say that yeah yeah
and he says it here
didn't wait wants conor mcgregor smart
channel it makes a lot of sense right
now interesting
but i don't know i really like chandler
connor after challenge last fight
there's plenty of fights to make i don't
know if that's the one but we'll see
what the landscape looks like when conor
comes back i'm just saying after the
last century his last fight counters
ranked eight he's ranked five it makes a
lot of sense right now ooh
and usually he's talking like that i
think he's getting better he's starting
to ramp up some training more and i'm
hoping at the end of this year early
next year
i'm i'm i'm down for that i'd be sick
100 down for that i think you do
chandler connor i think chandler would
be the favor of that fight when you do
chandler uh nate diaz let him take out
both those big boys
then chandler's off to the races scrooge
mcduck
making it rain going sizzler
fun fights man yeah
uh this is a quick one just de la hoya
he's changing his tune on dana white
right now he was on aerial show
he wants to bury the hatchet and he
wants them to work together
to build some sort of you know i don't
know
maybe happening it ain't happening could
be because boxing corrupt no matter what
you know and that's what dana said dan
was like that's a like because someone i
guess asked during the press conference
you know what they do
and he was like oh it's terrible it's
awful and then with dana and uh de la
hoya
you know dana went all all out on him
he's like how much cocaine is the guy
doing like it got really bad it got
really nasty so
and to take it from a guy who had his
issues with dana i've apologized and i'm
a fan you know when i did the they gave
me best dad and podcasting for father's
day right
and um they said who would what's the
number one guess you'd like to have on
you haven't had on i said dana white you
know i'd love to have dana on it but
you know
he he's not a guy who forgives very
easily you know
he's just not so and when it comes to de
la hoya you know de la hoya is going to
benefit more from dana than dana de la
hoya so i think de la hoya needs it he
put dana criticized me and all that for
good reason it's for a good reason for a
good reason it's for a good reason we're
saying good reason uh there was some
exchange going back forth me and dana
which i apologized him 100 percent i
think there's still a lot of business to
be done between me and dana in the
future if he ever wants to talk and sit
down never happening
imagine merging our two power
powerhouses together and creating
something together but for de la hoya
it's like you have golden boy promotions
but you don't have canelo anymore what
what's this powerhouse you're referring
to
dana's the powerhouse here um it would
be pretty unique i would love to work
with them i'm actually building a house
in las vegas i'm going to move there
full time to focus more on my business
than other businesses i have well but
yeah it would be a lot of fun
interesting to build something together
boxing is a very fragmented sport
uh what the fertitos brothers did and
dana did with the ufc is incredible i'm
extending olive branch i'd love to sit
down and talk and smooth things out let
bygones be by guns and then focus on
business not happening
i don't say that unless dana really
wants to do box and i think he does yeah
uh so check out this box right here what
is happening boxing dude last week that
was shadow boxing a ghost i know it
sucked and hide but yeah he died awful
yeah and then this guy bites his ear he
bites his neck oh i'll show you real
in that seventh round quick he attempt
to bite him here on the shoulder with a
mouthpiece though just feel like uh
like a baby donkey
or maybe he tried to kiss him like just
sucking on his neck you tried sucking it
they said the boxing match was kind of
going nowhere so he just kind of got
frustrated and trying to bite him on the
neck just because he was throwing uh
elbows
he said i was about to do a mic test on
him he kept throwing out was i don't
want to get cut i was ready to bite him
like mike tyson yeah people forget when
mike bit him but you know mike was kept
complaining about the head butts from
holyfield he was very frustrated that's
why he did it
and he says i want to apologize for my
actions but i said yesterday about mike
tyson bite i was in the moment got a
little ahead of myself it doesn't take
away from the embarrassment that i've
caused upon myself my team talk rank and
many others
but i do like to bite he didn't say that
i made them now
uh so that was weird
um yeah yeah but let's not bite though
you don't especially have a mouth reason
that's what i was thinking too like
i'm assuming mike spit his mouthpiece
out to rip the air off you can't do it
with a mouth you ever wore a mouthpiece
those things are thick yeah especially
the right ones
all right so alan belcher
uh former ufc fighter
he is now with the pkfc he's been doing
pretty good so this particular knockout
houston over the weekend was crazy
because how much saliva came out of this
guy's mouth really yeah i'll show you
right here first
boom yeah that's like some water man
like he held water in there
you could see it again
let's see if this should announce this
for bkfc
uh i know that's sean wheelock i don't
know the other ones
hold up here
yeah belcher's just laying fools out
boom a lot of water i agree right here
this is an unusual amount of water
you go
[Music]
yeah you got a clean knockout yeah
um oh we were just talking about this
right now so unfortunately these espn
broadcasters didn't know that that guy
died you know the guy that was punching
the air so they were kind of like
talking about like yeah we saw this
another guy do some crazy thing last
time blah blah and then just start
laughing right here
turns around almost goes to his
opponent's corner
to the neutral corner then turns around
almost goes to his opponent's corner
looks at that sound like he got busted
uh i'm holding i've seen worse there's a
video right now circulating right now
where a guy actually knocked another guy
out of the ring
he kept got back in the ring and the
other guy actually started boxing a
ghost in the corner
i'm serious he's boxing somebody in the
corner when the prep said box i'm
telling you
[Music]
it's not too bad okay let's get back no
it's not but there was laughing which
kind of sucks you know
yeah so but they did apologize
yeah i mean terrible terrible terrible
but how how would you know
yeah even on here we're like jesus
christ you know it was happening here
yeah boxing's had a rough time i want to
take a timeout right now apologies for
the last thing i made about a guy that
was actually punched someone in the
corner was punching a ghost in the
corner uh he actually passed away two
days ago i had no clue they passed away
i just want to give my utmost apology to
his family and his loved ones
i was unaware of the video you're
referencing
satori added i know you were just
telling a story based on
but there was uh the news this week of
sumiso who passed away yeah yeah so it
was tim bradley yeah xbox right now
what are you gonna do they didn't know
yeah
so jake paul announced that
the august fight is gonna be at msg and
just so far just him amanda serrano uh
he's fighting uh tommy fury i'm pretty
sure he's gonna fight tom yeah no that's
two he's fighting yeah yeah eddie hearn
uh leaked it oh okay yeah but msg huge
ass fans huge huge
god what he's done for amanda serrano is
nuts man
just blowing her up dude yeah i don't
know who she was before
uh this is also kind of crazy this is a
combat jiu jitsu so combat just so you
can open open hand palm strike you just
can't do you know a fist and this guy
knocked the guy out i think eddie
yeah he does one yeah
this eddie stuff take that left hand
madrid
oh he's out oh my goodness
damian anderson mike belchon adrian
madrid to sleep
god damn
palm strike it's interesting yeah it's
interesting way of doing jiu jitsu
it's cool
it's would you ever would i know back
then would you ever uh yeah i'd been up
for it
and darren till showed this someone
is a big fan of him and comes out
so he tattooed both of his uh legs with
their faces good artwork too yeah
yeah anytime anyone gets a tattoo
i mean you can't help but feel honored
yeah like that kid got the gringo poppy
tattoo on his ass
it's insane that's insane
it's cool yeah definitely cool that's
good artwork do it dude when you do uh
profiles like that you better have a
good artist otherwise you're like oh i
didn't know darren till has down
syndrome you know it's like
it's tough man
did you know blac chyna box over the
weekend too i did not
she like she bought some other like
instagram
i think model
she needs money huh i guess so but they
kind of go out of here
which one's blac chyna
from black
the girl she's fighting is
cheeked up dude girl she's fighting as
bad as [ __ ]
god blac chyna cannot box
oh
i've seen better fights on worlds it's
very messy why did they fight it was it
was a conflict um i don't know that you
know what's behind this i don't care
i was just trying to do my journalist
duty there
god the girl she fought was i'll show
you i actually pulled her
oh she up she's in uh alicia megan
fitness model she's a air force number
one booty oh wow wow wow wow wow that's
cool
that's cool yeah good for her well i
guess i ended up in a draw
yeah but don't fight huh girls let's not
do that
but she's definitely cheeked up yes yes
first team all body congrats
yeah she's really pretty
[ __ ] i'm not kim kardashian i'm gonna
knock you both out who's both
i don't know
[Music]
interesting yeah
yeah so who won the fight dude this is a
draw after all really yep
the whole thing the boy the poor girls
have to do this i don't know
but no but for both of them let's not do
any of this huh
i mean i didn't know who that girl was
so thank god she did it this is cool
uh you have a fight night though this
saturday night
free fights fight night espn austin
texas baby
uh maina vet
our brother from a new england mother
calvin keator is fighting josh emmett is
a phenomenal fight
and then the co-main event you got don
cerrone vs joe lauzon you got kevin
holland tim means
uh buckley's fighting albert you just
got some great fights on here man so i'm
excited for this card it's a good one
it's a really really good card
darren wayne you know him he's uh dc's
boy the shorter guy he really fights at
middleweight
um
yeah
that main card is tasty be tough to pick
fight of the night
really tough i'm i'm i am interested to
see uh cerrone uh joe lauzon
super and see those two
vets go at it kevin hollington means
phenomenal fight kevin holland big big
favorite there calvin kader slightly
favorite i told him that i regret
telling that you used to hate when
people did that to me
but uh yeah can't wait for that main
event
i think calvin ketter gets done via
decision
is that it chin that's it 4pm
perspective it's p.m pacific all right
all right that's in austin texas
that is on espn fight night
um i get some time off madame in la uh
living my best life
uh for the summer uh we're still doing
dates around l.a you'll see me i'm doing
spots all over the improv and factory
and other stuff like that but the next
shop and friends is next wednesday june
22nd shopping friends have some monsters
with me there
and then the trash panda tour continues
in fort wayne indiana that is fort wayne
indiana one of the only places i've
not been uh my uncle was born i think
it's a military town my uncle was born
there my uncle charlie shout to charlie
that's july 14th through the 16th san
diego california downtown heart of san
diego laugh factory san diego phenomenal
club down there excited for this i
featured for dalia down there i've never
been there so i'm excited for that's
july 21st through july 23rd then
baltimore is august 4th through the 6th
appleton just got added appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
houston september 15th to 17th and like
i told calvin keator you can see the new
england cartel at the show boston laugh
boston i'm there for a full week and you
just do the wilbur but i decided to do a
freaking club so i'm there september
29th through october 1st at laugh boston
in boston
um but fort wayne indiana and san diego
you're up next tickets at thickboy.com
uh that's it man thank you for watching
summer is upon us so have a great summer
keep those summer bodies boom and daddy
keep those ass cheeks out the back of
the jean shorts get on some rollerblades
do your thing man do your thing and it
is a thick boy summer i love you guys be
safe thanks for watching like subscribe
comment whatever you want to do love you
guys see you around
you